joe biden is absolutely flailing we had
a poll last week quinnipiac suggesting
that his approval rating was down to 33
well now we have a second poll from
civics suggesting that his approval
rating is at 34 so this makes two
straight polls in which joe biden is in
the low 30s these are abysmal numbers if
you are the president of the united
states and this follows hard on a
morning and console political poll
that shows that only 11 percent of
americans after one year give joe biden
in a grade as president of the united
states and only another 20 give him a b
which means that 69 of americans say
that joe biden is a c or below president
including 37 percent of americans who
say that he's got an f so this guy is a
fail he is a giant fail and as we
discussed yesterday he's failing on
every front well the biden
administration because they have no
capacity to shift gears they are not
clintonian joe biden is not bill clinton
he's not a talented politician like
barack obama he he's nothing he's a big
nothing burger of a human and he's been
a nothing burger of a human since he
entered the senate and was quickly seen
to be a bloviating bag of plagiarism
ever since then the president of the
united states has had a really tough
time shifting gears he is not somebody
who shifts and moves quickly he is
somebody who sort of bobs atop the
eddies of political life he's not a
leader he's not somebody who is going to
forcibly move forward his agenda he is
just a guy who happens to be kind of
dead center of where
where the democratic party is at any
given point and and that means that he
does not have the capacity to change
course he cannot do it
and and so when his administration
basically said you know what we've got a
comms problem here and this was the
story over the last few days we need to
shift comms right whenever a politician
says and when they start leaking stories
to the press about how they are going to
shift communication strategy
you know that this politician is a
failure when they say they're going to
shift political strategy you know that
the politician might actually be capable
of changing
but when they're refusing to change any
of their political strategies they're
just going to shift how they talk to
people forget it because politicians are
what they are i've yet to see a
politician who's capable of of really
shifting what they are well what made
bill clinton very effective is that bill
clinton was
incredibly malleable as a politician
one day he could be conservative one day
he could be far left
but his mannerisms were not particularly
malleable right he just had broad range
as an actor bill clinton had broad range
right sometimes he was crying in front
of camera denying things and the next
day he was crying apologizing for the
same things sometimes he was doing
jovial bill clinton sometimes he was
doing sad and empathetic bill clinton he
had a lot of range barack obama didn't
have a lot of range but he had a lot of
charisma joe biden has neither ranged
nor charisma and so when his team says
we need to get you out in front of the
cameras more the first reaction for
anyone smart inside the white house
should have been no we don't
no we don't this guy became president
literally because he did not get in
front of cameras it is amazing how many
politicians think they are popular
because people like them as opposed to
being popular because people hate their
opponents
politics is oppositional by nature and
people do not love joe biden and they
certainly don't love him after what he
did in afghanistan which is when his
polls really tanked okay so yesterday
joe biden decides i need to save this
presidency it's time to save the
presidency i'm going to do a press
conference
at this point jen saki started drinking
heavily
jens hockey picked the wrong way to stop
sniffing glue man so joe biden decides
he's going to hold his first presser in
months and for all of those wondering
why joe biden doesn't do press
conferences this would be the reason
the man went on for two long
interminable hours
he started babbling nonsensically
he started stepping all over his own
you-know-what
he he is not capable this is not a
capable competent coherent president he
is not
so
this whole thing opens with him being
asked by zeke miller from the associated
press about whether he overpromised when
he entered office because he said he was
going to shut down the virus and he was
going to create a booming economy he was
going to bring world peace all the rest
of it and joe biden's answer was of
course defensive because joe biden is a
defensive nasty person this has been
true in the senate forever it was true
on the campaign trail he literally said
on the campaign trail to a detractor a
bernie sanders fan detractor he
literally said look fat
to the guy i mean that's who joe biden
is so he does that with a reporter here
did you over promise to the american
public what you could achieve in your
first year in office and how do you plan
to course correct going forward why are
you such an optimist
look
i didn't over promise
and but i have probably uh
outperformed what anybody thought would
happen
the fact of the matter is that uh
we're in a situation where uh
we have made enormous progress
he said he's outperformed expectations
unless those expectations were that he
would have a zero percent approval
rating he has not outperformed
expectations this is a person whose
delta between high approval rating and
low approval rating is about 16 percent
went from about 50 54 more than that
almost 20 percent he's down from about
54 all the way down to low 30s according
to some of these polls
that's a huge delta
so no and one of the reasons is because
he's absolutely incoherent so yesterday
i mean it's it's hard to watch these
press conferences with joe biden because
you you do feel in real time that you
may be watching the last joe biden press
conference you feel like he might
actually physically keel over his brain
just stops functioning in the middle of
these
in the middle of these exchanges
it's incredible
right he he's just
incoherent
so here is a here is joe biden
rambling and then going silent talking
about talking about the voters the voter
who
is just trying to figure out as i said
how to take care of their family put
three squares on the table stay safe be
able to pay their mortgage or their rent
etc
has is becoming
much more informed on
the um
the motives of
um
some of the political
players
and some of the
and the political parties it's all fine
this is fine dog dot jiff
dog in fiery room
you know i used to live in boston for
three years when i was in law school and
uh being from a very warm climb i was
not used to the icy conditions and so i
remember one time i went over to the
local kosher grocery store to pick up
some food and like an idiot i parked on
the ice i didn't know anything so i
parked on the ice so i get back in the
car and i start trying to
gun the engine to to you know actually
move the car and the car is going
nowhere the the wheels are just spinning
and spinning and spinning and spinning
that is joe biden's brain right now it's
just spinning and it's going nowhere
there's no traction there
he is not with us this is a president
who is not with us and so he's asked you
know um some people question her mental
fitness he's like
come on man
why do you suppose
such large segments of the american
electorate
have come to harbor
such profound concerns
about your cognitive fitness thank you
i have no idea
yeah i'm sure he doesn't i am sure he
doesn't the good news about a press
conference this bad for joe biden is
that he doesn't remember it even now
within five minutes it was gone from his
brain
okay also i mean again i can just show
you clip after clip from this press
conference just play him over and over
of joe biden completely falling apart
there's a point where he said i mean
he's going to ask a rhetorical question
no he won't by the way his dead giveaway
in terms of body language is him
clutching
his portfolio he's got this portfolio
that usually sits on the deck he starts
clutching it defensively almost it's
bizarre i don't think there's been much
on any incoming president's plate that's
been a bigger menu than the plate i had
given to me i'm not complaining knew
that running in
and the fact of the matter is we got an
awful lot done
an awful lot done
and there's more to get done but look
let's let me ask a rhetorical question
no i will anyway
is going on
what is going on and then just kind of
clutching his portfolio that what is
happening what's happening
then he's asked about the polls and
question who said it donald trump or joe
biden fake news fake paws
it was really bad when trump said it
right trump wasn't allowed to job polls
but joe biden does it all the time here
we go
how do you plan to win back moderates
and independents who cast a ballot for
you in 2020 but polls indicate aren't
happy with the way you're doing your job
now i don't believe the pulse oh he
doesn't believe the polls so i guess
they don't exist anymore that's not he's
not casting inspiration to the press he
just doesn't believe the polls and good
news for democrats this
geriatric daughter is going to be
heavily involved in the midterms he says
congratulations to all you democrats in
purple district and i hope that you have
a nice lobbying job lined up because man
it ain't going to go great
i'm going to be deeply involved
in the off these off your elections
uh-oh we're going to be raising a lot of
money we're going to be out there making
sure that we're helping all of those
candidates and scores of them already
asked me to come in and campaign with
them to go out and make the case
in plain simple language as to what it
is we've done what we want to do and why
we think it's important now for all
those battleground
con for all those battleground congress
people and senators it's time to break
out that sad trombone from the price is
right
joe biden jet setting into your
territory is probably your worst
nightmare right you're running a
competitive race and here comes an
incoherent and
he just he's got nothing and that guy's
gonna jet in and he's gonna fix your
race good luck with that
on topic on topic after topic yesterday
joe biden just crapped the bed i mean he
just made a mess and jenn saki who's the
night nurse of the white house she had
to try and fix some of these things but
again jensaki picked the wrong way to
stop doing math
this is this is not the right week for
that
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist here that
is just science
[Music]